barroso first pick it up with a little
game historical figure or rapper where
we will give you a quote and you will
have to guess if that is a visitor
whatwhat good rapport a per all right
all right we know your history buffs so
we figured you'd get yeah right so
number one law is mind without reason
historical figure or rapper I wouldn't
say historical figure but maybe that's
what they want us to say that's Italian
too true what kind of an historic figure
would not believe in wall but a rapper
might be like de los sucks right it's so
like a Tupac or something yeah so what
are we gonna say what do you think
rapper I think historian I'll go along
so final answer historian yeah look in
that face correct was it was it was the
fantastic rapper Lil Wayne next one I am
a mirror what you see is what you
reflect knowing I am a mirror what you
see is what you reflect now that sounds
like a rapper to me it does sound like a
rapper why are they all being tricky
Dicky with I don't know but it's a
rapper correct Hey yay who says American
royalty jay-z oh I am far too busy
writing history to read it I mean that's
not like a trick question rapper Kanye
yeah yeah did he really say that he
really said that I am far too busy
writing history to read it we did
Michael Bay and we kind of had that same
kind of a program like Michael Bay's
almost joking impression of kanye the
rapper I don't think it's joking at all
i think they're equally is calm I felt
slightly in love with him in the course
of making that rap battle though there's
something so like I feel like he'd be
funny to have around when I do good I
feel good when I do bad I feel bad
that's my religion that's alright sounds
like a rapper right if it starts with I
I feel like it's a rabbit huh yeah
rapper incorrect I I way this is a quote
that is usually attributed to Abraham
Lincoln shenanigans he's a rapper next
yeah from us i'm always about the
creativity because it was learning how
to use what we had so when we were in a
bedroom we were going in the closet
making it sound all right like figuring
it out and then we started making rap
battles really had a couple hundred
bucks